he's John Barry from the mothership
former NBA veteran he was on the call
for Rockets Lakers last night on ESPN
Radio good morning John how are you Wow
a lot going on my liver what who is that
talking about my Liverpool Reds that was
Sofie appreciated that that was Sophie
in Los Angeles she's my unpaid
correspondent okay well
Liverpool's not choking by the way mmm
doesn't it meet Friday yes it is it is a
meet Friday yeah we got tacos you got
wings yeah we've got meat Friday's songs
we've got it all and we've got some
issues with refereeing last night with
Scott Foster out to get James Harden
apparently or James Harden out to get
Scott Foster let me play what harden had
to say after the game he had for
charging fouls this is what he had to
say about Scott Foster just just rude
and arrogant
I mean you aren't able to talk to him
throughout the course of the game and
it's like how do you do their
relationship with the fish was you know
so and it's live in that Hall like this
is just you know who he is on that
floors it's pretty frustrating and I
mean I'm probably a hit but honestly I
don't really say anything I'm pretty
quiet guard to myself but it's one of
those things where you can't voice your
pay you can't have a conversation with
some of us officiating the game and you
know you're getting it take this it's
pretty sad you feel like a date there is
date it's a personal yeah for sure for
sure it's personal for sure like I don't
think you should be able to even know
officiate our games anymore honestly do
you think this is a perceived slight by
Harden or it's real
well you know Scott foster if I'm not
mistaken had a issue with Chris Paul
last year yeah
when I think Chris Paul said something
like people are paying to see Scott
foster play or officiate so there's some
beef there now I mean come on I don't I
know Scott Foster is one of those guys
that is not embracing a lot of
conversation with players and that's
just kind of the way it is I mean we've
had officials throughout the years that
have been like that you know there were
nights when joe crawford who's one of
the great officials we've ever had that
you just simply don't talk to him so if
you know that on that given night you
just don't do it and you you know that's
up to the players they should know that
and whatever I I sat there i watch there
were four you know charging calls in his
heart that I thought three of them were
poor calls but that's the way it goes
and to see two guys fall out of the best
players though I was wondering when's
the last time you see that in the NBA
but I'm also wondering is Scott Foster
is he old school calling what should be
called whereas it feels like there's a
little more latitude when it comes to
James Harden he initiates contact you
know the step back or stepped to the
side that's not traveling it feels like
Harden benefits a little bit more from
the officiating than he is penalized by
it yeah I mean he goes to the line more
than any player in the NBA so you know
to come out and really say this I think
it's surprising I think it's a very good
move by James he gets the benefit of the
doubt he is the one that creates all the
contact he's very difficult to officiate
he's so crafty when he dribbles into the
lane and he throws his arms and the
people and he huge three points you know
shots that he gets fouled more than
anybody in the league so I don't know
not a great move really to talk about it
it was you know yeah he had some tough
calls last night I totally agree but at
the same time over the totality of the
season I think he's on the upper end
what's the league office to figure out
what kind of money they're gonna make
from James and they can't get ready for
a check
do you give him an audience if you're
the commissioner do you call James
Harden I know I said I would because I
just want to know you know how he came
up you know with this opinion here and I
also want to talk to Scott Foster and
just say look I I we can't have this
yeah you know there it there is this
perception there but I can't have my
star player calling out the officials
and I want to know if Scott Foster does
have a problem with James Harden yeah I
mean maybe you you know you investigate
that I mean talk to James about it you
know you you you tell me you show me the
evidence that this is something personal
but aren't they great and after every
game yeah well it'll fall on deaf ears
look their mission calls on a nightly
basis i I don't think Scott Foster was
out to go get James Harden last night in
any stretch income there were a couple
calls that were tough calls on them you
know and that's gonna happen especially
when the guy has the ball the whole game
and makes all the players that James
Harden does I the Lakers
this was poll question in the first hour
of the show is that a successful season
if the Lakers make the postseason sure
you know just to become relevant really
I mean when LeBron one here this is not
a roster that was you know suited for
LeBron it wasn't it wasn't made out to
be for LeBron and they didn't have any
opportunity really to do that once they
got him so you know you look at the
shooting I mean my gosh the shooting
last night the three points we did was
just dismal yeah they're one of the
worst in the league they've been that
they've been that way throughout the
whole season you know and to me last
night
that was a group in the first and third
quarter that really looked disengaged
fragmented didn't look like a group that
was fighting to get into the playoffs
they were down 19 points in the third
quarter and Houston basically just kind
of the way they play allowed teams back
in the games but man I saw LeBron James
looking over at the bench time and time
again after three-point shot would come
up missing and just he did not look
happy in this group with all that trade
talked with Anthony Davis there's got to
be something in that locker room that
feels awkward when you know
one of the best players in the league he
and his people had said any of you guys
we want out of here to get here to Davis
yeah I brought this up it's a
hypothetical but I it's just an
interesting question I think if you were
the Lakers and you could trade LeBron
for Anthony Davis would you do that
his current age yeah right now right now
no yes you would because then I don't
have to get rid of any of these kids I
still have money for free agents and
free agents are more likely to go there
with Anthony Davis there than LeBron
James well I just want to win right now
you're not winning right now no LeBron
doesn't have any choice in the matter
that's why I'm saying you'd have to
trade him you get Anthony Davis you keep
that roster you got money to spend and
then you could bring in Kawhi Leonard or
you could bring in you know somebody
else who might want to play with that
roster as opposed to going into the
circus that is the Lakers now yeah I
know yeah I could see that you know cuz
cuz who is gonna want to come here and
play with LeBron that's the question I
mean I guess the you're probably gonna
pull off the Davis deal this summer but
I mean is that even good enough do you
think the leaders see I think Boston's
got more to offer it feels like they do
but if it has to include Tatum I yeah
you would yeah mm-hmm so you got
basically you'd have Horford Irving if
if Irving comes back we don't know
what's gonna happen there July 1st yeah
yeah yeah so it's gonna be interesting
and I don't know what's gonna I do
believe that Kevin Durant plays
elsewhere next year you do yeah you done
I say he stays really well why not go if
they win again they're gonna go for
Florida round ones the last time that
happened that's the Celtics I believe
right back in the 60s but I don't think
that he still is going to get the
respect that he wants for doing
something like that
he's the Finals MVP again I don't know
it feels like hey I've sort of done what
I wanted to do you now you can't say you
didn't win a title or you weren't the
MVP of the final like I've done that
I've accomplished that and if he wins
this time around it just feels like okay
now I'm gonna do something that is gonna
raise my profile my resume where I'm
gonna be on equal footing with LeBron
James when it's all said and done I'm
gonna take the Knicks and I'm gonna I'm
gonna win a championship there I'm gonna
get Kyrie to come down from Boston I'm
gonna get Kyrie yes with with Kevin
Durant and Kyrie Irving and iron and
Zion
just think I'm just throwing that out
there I think Kevin's law I think he's
sensitive to sensitive I think being
labeled the guy who ruined the NBA I I
think it affects him and I think that he
wants that next challenge to be able to
do something that will really mark his
legacy I felt that from the beginning of
the year that I didn't think he was
going back to Golden State okay so go to
New York they'll be easy on there well
they'll be easier from the standpoint of
they're desperate they're welcoming em
in the rest of you know basketball the
fans are you have a problem with Kevin
Durant with Golden State nobody's gonna
have a problem with him there and they
probably root for Kevin Durant if he
went to the Knicks the media would be
nice and sensitive to I'm sure they and
I on they're gonna want a championship
next year okay okay well good luck if I
give you if I put Durant and Kyrie in
and Zion Williamson on the Knicks right
now next season yeah why are you salty
today what would happen here it feels
like why does Kevin why would Kevin
Durant leave a situation like Golden
State I don't I mean like the guy is
killing it off the floor he's owning
Silicon Valley he's got a 400 million
dollar Nike deal what would his legacy
is why I mean the guy is unbelievable
like he I have no
problem with him going to go instead do
you think he could win five titles in
Golden State and he's not going to be
considered better than Kobe or LeBron
you know some of these other guys right
probably not know yeah you know but I
mean is he gonna lose any sleep over
that I don't know it feels like he loses
sleep over little things though John
he's a sensitive guy yeah yes that's
gonna make at the bottom line is he's
gonna do what makes him happy and if
that's if that's moving on to a inferior
team and trying to bring them to
prominence then so be it
he wants to say oh I don't have a
problem with these days I just think if
he's not gonna help LeBron so you're not
gonna go to the Lakers and I just
thought if he does leave he's not gonna
go back to his hometown in Washington DC
the Knicks
if the knick whoever wins the lottery I
won I'm curious what that will do for
possible free agency of you know wanting
to play with Zion or that opportunity to
have somebody young who can come in and
all of a sudden you know there's great
interest there and you're relevant if
you're a bad team yeah no I mean the NBA
is all about reality TV now right I mean
the summer time is what we're all
worried about we can't we can't wait
with who's going where and what's gonna
happen and it's like the Kardashians all
over again you sure you're not salty
today all right no I'm enjoying myself
and okay Friday I had a song and I was
thinking about gonna meet Friday all
right I'm ready
you're gonna sing it well well I'm a
horrible singer okay I did carry it I
did karaoke when I was 18 and they had a
tape of it they gave it to me the next
day when I woke up hungover and I've
never done it again all right it was
awful so well so Lionel Richie right
hello
yeah the song yeah okay so is it me
you're looking for but is it me we're
looking for I like it we're off to a
good start
I mean that's okay right I mean yeah let
me hear ya
is it hello is it meat we're looking for
and that's that's as far as you've got
with the lyrics I could see it in your
chicken thighs instead of eyes you can
go we got it
well why don't we the way Dan yeah dan
dan one of the best Johnny Cash's out
there I'll give you credit they'll
remember remember us in Utah doing you
and I went Utah you remember I don't
remember okay well you sang on the stage
at Utah bar that turned out to be all
guys when we look around it's just a
coincidence John I hope they appreciated
my Johnny Cash there I'd love to get a
day at Pebble with y'all next year that
looks like a blast we should come out
you think I could sit at the back of the
range for a day yeah yeah yeah that'd be
cool
just bang balls and you know Faldo stops
by and jordan Spieth and Rory and yeah
no they were great I mean the Faldo
Sergio that was really good photo is
really funny he is yeah love him on the
air I think he's great
his sense of humor he's really good
we're gonna work on the other very well
I know he was it was boring
but I don't think she cared about being
liked ya know well he was pretty damn
good yeah yeah I think he was out there
to win he wasn't out there to make
friends all right I have to go it's me
Friday yeah okay all right okay just all
right that's John Barry ESPN basketball
analyst for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
you
[Music]